Apollo 13 flight controllers in the ago
no go for launch
you know that Easter vacation trip we
had on an for Acapulco procedures don't
control go fight there might be a slight
change in destination baby maybe say the
moon booster go retro go go flight GNC
when I take the controls and I steered
around FAO we're go flight or a nice
soft landing on the moon better than a
large truck does it bother you that the
public regards this flight is routine
it's nothing routine about flying to the
moon I could buy it for that large
control this is Houston we are go for
launch
clear the town red
guys gonna move this is a crew of Apollo
13 wishing everyone back on earth
Blizzard evening houston we have a
problem
we got a wicked shimmy up here houston
we are printing something out into space
it's definitely a gas of some sort like
the heart rates are skyrocketing the
Apollo 13 spacecraft is apparently
losing breathing oxygen the emergency
has ruled out any chance of a lunar
landing why are so many people here
something broken your daddy's spaceship
but I have a request from the news
people take it up with my husband he'll
be home on Friday so I am lost the radio
contact you come what's your daddy
telling you it's reading a quadruple
failure that can't happen it's gotta be
instrumentation we're exploiting it at
this rate we're gonna skip right out of
the atmosphere and we're never gonna get
back but we're looking at less than 15
minutes elapse important the opposite we
never lost an American in space with
shirts he'll not gonna lose wha how to
see him do you read me
but how long does it take to power up
the LEM three hours by the checklist
you don't have that much time